[Music]  [Music]  mrs wang are you with us  i am paying attention  now you may only see a pile of receipts  but i see a story  i can see where this story is going  it does not look  good  what's happening  i'm not your husband i'm one of the  first uniform from another universe i'm  here because we need your help  very busy today so time to help you  across the  seen multiverse of evidence  we can access all the memories their  emotions  even the skills  there's a great evil spreading the many  verses  and you  may be your only chance of stopping it  don't make me find you i am really good  i don't believe you  he's waiting in the wings the universe  he speaks of senseless things is so much  bigger  than you realize  of all the places  [Music]  there is no way i am the evelyn you are  looking for  every rejection  every disappointment  has led you here  to this  moment  don't let anything distract you from it  [Music]  uh  [Music]  you